merci Arnaud et oui nous sommes de
retour sur le plateau de la vallée libre
avec nos invités Denis Roland acteurs de
l'Académie Anne Dylan Seger adjointe au
maire de Dijon délégal éducation Gilles
plattret maire de Chalon-sur-Saône et
Dominique beau président de la FCPE de
Côte-d'Or un tweet d'abord une question
de peut-être si quelqu'un vous réagir
peut-être Monsieur le Recteur là je te
laisse scolarité obligatoire ne
devrait-il pas être abaissé à 4,5 ans
pour mieux inculquer les valeurs
républicaines ces Chailloux 71 qui nous
disent peut-être quelqu'un de
Chalon-sur-Saône vous savez que depuis
quelques années on travaille à la
scolarisation des enfants de moins de 3
ans partout où c'est nécessaire partout
notamment les parents au moins la
capacité d'accompagner leurs enfants et
les accompagner vers non seulement la
réussite scolaire mais la réussite
citoyenne donc on est bien dans cette
direction là dans chaque
Vallaud-Belkacem a annoncé dans toutes
ces mesures un parcours citoyen de 3 ans
de 300 heures si je ne m'abuse du
primaire au lycée donc ça fait 25 heures
paradis je me suis amusé à faire le
calcul ce sera veut dire une heure par
semaine pour tous les élèves c'est ça
qui est important c'est suffisant sur
l'enseignement moral civique l'éducation
médias à l'info c'est si on enlève pas
ce qu'on fait c'est à dire que
l'éducation civique va rester dans le
giron du professeur
d'histoire-géographie mais à côté de
cela et quel que soit l'enseignant à
l'élémentaire comme dans le secondaire
au collège et au lycée on va avoir une
heure de débat de réflexion de dialogue
avec l'enseignant ou avec un enseignant
pour réfléchir à ses valeurs du vivre
ensemble pour réfléchir à ce que ça veut
dire que l'égalité la fraternité la
liberté la liberté d'expression pour
comprendre que la laïcité c'est pas
l'exclusion mais c'est au contraire le
fait d'unir les citoyens les fêtes de
les réunir quel que soit leur croyances
et c'est vraiment nouveau parce que
envie de réagir justement j'ai vu des
parents d'élèves qui disaient oui Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem réinvente l'eau tiède
vous vous pensez quoi de ces mesures
non ce que je veux dire c'est enfin ça
elle le pose elle le pose donc ça veut
dire qu'il se fera que ce soit fait nous
ce qu'on aimerait aussi c'est évidemment
que
ce soit en fait qu'il y a une heure pour
ça d'accord qu'il y ait une évaluation
pas des élèves mais qui n'évaluation des
enseignants sur ce que ça a apporté sur
ce que ça amène mais j'ai tendance à
dire que ça ça doit être fait tous les
jours tout le temps à chaque heure ça
c'est important
c'est vraiment quelque chose nous au
niveau des parents
le professeur de sciences et vie de la
terre comme le professeur de n'importe
quelle discipline est capable dans son
cours dans son dialogue avec les élèves
d'apprendre le respect mutuel et de
faire passer nos valeurs ça
effectivement il faut le rappeler et il
faut aussi mieux la prendre aux jeunes
enseignants pour qu'ils apprennent à le
transmettre
les élus qui n'ont pas réagi vous en
pensez quoi vous de ce parcours citoyen
alors c'est utile c'est oui oui alors
c'est utile mais effectivement là pour
le coup je suis d'accord sur le fait que
il faut que ce soit à tout moment et
dans tous les cours sur le vivre
ensemble le respect de l'autre
et donc pour aller aussi jusqu'au
jusqu'aux parents effectivement il faut
aussi que que les parents quand ils
entrent dans l'école quand ils rentrent
dans les dans les lieux publics soit
aussi respectueux et n'incendit pas la
personne qui se trouve au guichet et
parce que ça aussi c'est compliqué et
donc il faut absolument que
ce parcours citoyen il se décline à tous
les moments de la journée à tous les
moments de la journée sur toutes les
heures de cours et donc sur les autres
moments où l'enfant est en collectif
évidemment on a tous les moyens de le
faire
bon le plante est qu'il a été présenté
et et plein de de mesures de bon sens
encore une fois je dis que ce qui ce qui
doit nous interroger c'est qu'il arrive
maintenant quand on dit qu'il faut
réaffirmer le respect des maîtres est-ce
qu'il faut est-ce qu'il fallait 17 morts
pour arriver à réaffirmer le respect des
maîtres peuvent permettre c'est pas la
première fois qu'on le redit mais bien
sûr donc je pense que ça c'est les
annonces est-ce que c'est de l'eau tiède
est-ce que c'est de l'eau froide est-ce
que c'est de l'eau chaude ça se bon
c'est une autre question c'est des
annonces il fallait que des annonces il
fallait qu'il y ait une réaction elles
auraient peut-être pu être orientés
autrement peu importe mais ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est notre capacité à les
faire durer dans le temps parce que si
ça doit rester un effet d'annonce ça ne
marchera pas une heure par semaine c'est
nécessaire ça n'est pas suffisant il
faut aller au-delà et je rejoins ma
collègue élu adjointe de Dijon il faut
abandonner que nous nous saisissions
dans l'ensemble de la sphère publique de
ces matières là l'école a un rôle à
jouer je suis pas sûrement qu'en
assurant une journée de la laïcité le 9
décembre on sauve
réenseigner réapprendre se réapproprier
ces valeurs et c'est pour ça que moi je
salue par exemple l'attitude de
l'Association des maires de France qui
s'est saisi des dossiers qui veut le
valoriser parce que c'est essentiel
c'est notre société qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui et c'est notre société tout
entière qui doit se mobiliser pour
réapprendre les valeurs du respect et de
la tolérance de niveau
je vais je vais en relire à l'école je
vais juste en revenir à l'école en
parlant du respect du maître bien sûr
bien sûr que c'est quelque chose qui est
important mais l'élève va respecter le
maître et donc ensuite l'adulte si déjà
se mettre est respecté par les parents
ça c'est quelque chose qui est important
ce qui veut donc dire qu'il faut à tout
prix ça c'est quelque chose c'est ça
doit à l'école doit évoluer c'est à dire
que enfin on doit avoir des parents et
des enseignants
en tout cas qui travaillent ensemble oui
qui travaille ensemble qui coeduque
ensemble cet enfant ce qui veut vous
avez lu comme moi le dossier du
ministère d'éducation nationale à propos
de ces mesures les parents d'élèves
doivent être associés à la démarche via
un comité départementale d'éducation à
la santé à la citoyenneté ça c'est une
bonne chose est-ce que c'est du blabla
est-ce que ça ne convient pas du blabla
ça peut être du blabla si ça reste en
état actuel c'est du blabla simplement
je pense que la société n'évoluera pas
si ça reste du blabla l'enfant il passe
d'une sphère à une autre il faut qu'on
apprenne à
coéduquer moi je suis désolé on en
revient toujours à la même chose à
coéduquer l'enfant on arrive à discuter
avec les avec tout ce qui est
périscolaire parce que le périscolaire
est plus proche des parents et on n'a
pas ce côté
ce côté note ce côté sanction de d'une
éducation maintenant il faut qu'on
arrive à faire la même chose avec les
enseignants et il faut je pense que les
parents vont rentrer dans l'école ça
risque de ne pas obligatoirement très
bien se passer parce qu'il y a un manque
il y a un manque de communication donc
comme quand on arrive je finirai comme
quand on arrive à un guichet on arrive
en étant Ivan il va encore s'arrêter
pile quand tu vas arriver ça va donc
obligatoirement on est agressif il va
falloir que cette agressivité quelque
part sorte par rapport à certains
parents mais on apprenne à la calmer
qu'on apprenne à discuter qu'on apprenne
à gérer et ensuite on travaille tous
ensemble ça il va falloir qu'on la
prenne on a l'impression de nirlande que
finalement tout le monde est d'accord
parent profs vous responsable de
l'éducation nationale pour le constat
pour ce qu'il faut faire mais que dans
chaque établissement ça va peut-être pas
se concrétiser aussi bien que cela c'est
pour ça qu'il faut qu'on forme mieux les
enseignants les jeunes enseignants
particuliers y compris à la relation aux
parents à
à la relation avec l'environnement aussi
un enseignant il n'est jamais hors sol
il est dans son contexte il est dans son
environnement mais vous savez on apprend
l'élève apprend avec ses parents l'élève
apprend avec à l'école l'élève va
prendre dans le périscolaire et c'est
tout ce milieu qui doit se mettre en
ordre de meilleures fonctionnement pour
réinsérer ses valeurs du respect de la
tolérance du vivre ensemble et ça c'est
vraiment important mettre au fronton des
écoles libertés égalité fraternité avec
un drapeau européen et un drapeau
français c'est réapprendre quelque chose
il faut que partout on explique aussi ce
que ça veut dire pourquoi il y a ça papa
pourquoi il y a sa maman et que les
parents soient en mesure d'expliquer ça
veut dire effectivement les parents
doivent rentrer dans l'école les
enseignants doivent travailler mais ils
le font mais il faut aussi mieux les
aider parfois avec les parents de façon
à ce que on sache que la formation ça
s'arrête pas à la sortie de l'école
c'est un tout
ça aussi notre devenir de vivre ensemble
d'ailleurs le ministère je crois veux
aussi faire participer les collectivités
locales mais c'est déjà le cas non à la
réussite éducative qu'est-ce qui peut
changer
ce qui peut changer
on le voit bien mais c'est surtout que
nous on n'a pas attendu le 7 janvier on
a on a un projet éducatif qui est
décliné depuis 2003 un projet éducatif
global qui a été voté à l'unanimité je
dois le dire par tous les élus de la
ville de Dijon le 28 juin 2012 et donc
qui qui vraiment prend prend
en compte toute cette toute cette
nécessité de vivre ensemble de
travailler autour des droits de l'homme
des droits de l'enfant et et cela on le
décline notamment dans tous les
périscolaires et l'extrascolaire où
chaque animateur doit se poser la
question à partir de l'action la plus
simple à la plus compliquée en quoi mon
et éducative voilà et je pense que si
déjà on se pose cette question par
rapport aux valeurs de la République on
a la chance d'avoir une devise
extraordinaire liberté égalité
fraternité alors faisons la vivre et
posons-nous la question aujourd'hui en
quoi je vais pouvoir faire vivre cette
devise dans les activités que je vais
mener votre conclusion aussi bien sûr il
y a des symboles qui sont
incontournables le drapeau fait partie
de ces symboles et en plus il s'est
adjoint le drapeau de l'Europe qui est
aussi l'objectif de notre espérance donc
ces deux drapeaux sont fondamentaux la
devise ça n'est pas négociable et le
respect et même la participation des
jeunes aux cérémonies patriotiques ça
c'est quelque chose de fort pour
communier dans un esprit national que
nous pouvons partager quel que soit nos
origines et c'est quelque chose que nous
on essaye de mettre en place à
Chalon-sur-Saône d'une manière accentuée
mais
il n'y aura pas de survie de nos
principes si nous ne débordons pas le
cadre de l'école la politique de la
ville qui aujourd'hui a montré ses
limites la politique du renouvellement
urbain qui n'a pas créé assez de mixité
qui a même engendré des ghettos ces
dernières années doivent être
questionnés de fond en comble c'est
l'ensemble des politiques publiques qui
doivent être remises sur la table
rediscuter pour mettre l'humain et le
vivre ensemble dans le système
républicain et dans l'acceptation de nos
différences mais avec une vue d'unité
nationale qui doit être au cœur d'une
discussion demain elle nous serait la
dernière à part les madame pour les
parents d'élèves un dernier mot ça vous
a rassuré cette espèce de finalement de
volonté commune
je n'avais pas besoin d'être rassuré je
vous remercie et je vous remercie non
quelques secondes c'est pas possible non
j'étais persuadé suite à ce qui s'est
tendance à dire que ce qui s'est passé
il faut vraiment qu'on s'en serve
j'aimerais juste une chose c'est qu'on
aille plus vite on a eu juste plus vite
que dans les classes on continue à se
servir et et en parler et qu'on
n'attendent pas les générations doivent
pas être sacrifiées pour
et bien nous continuons nous
continuerons à suivre ça merci en tout
cas à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation on en arrive au terme de
cette édition déjà ça passe très vite je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet Google France 3.fr la semaine
prochaine la voie libre reviendra sur la
conférence de presse du Président de la
République qui aura lieu jeudi pour
l'heure c'est le 12 13 qui se poursuit
très belle après-midi à tous